we want to move forward in what we can
do what we're able to
um uh manipulate with these fractions
okay so we've just been looking at what
they are
putting them in the right order let's
put it together and you know
see them get in a fight or something
like that okay adding and subtracting
we'll get on to multiplication division
later
right now i have a question for you
one plus one this is equal to two
i look at this and i see well this
number and this time they go together
okay well if i have fractions
i see this number and this number go
together and i see this number and this
number
they go together that's not right
so wait a second if it's not right
what's the problem i followed exactly
the same rule that we did before with
whole numbers
why are you telling me it's wrong don't
just tell me it is
how can you justify that it's wrong
okay all right so someone says to me
someone suggests
i don't add the denominator i'm just
going to come back to you and say
that's correct why why not add the donut
you guys you guys are racist you're
going to add new awareness but not too
honest that's unfair
okay can you give me an actual reason
crystal cause like the two describes
what the
one is like we're suggesting there's
something different about these twos
okay it's not racist they are actually
they are actually saying something
different so that's why you do something
different to them but can we
push on this a little more do you want
to go first yeah
so okay you have proved to me
fine i'm satisfied that this is wrong
but i still don't know why i can't add
these
twos we're getting there but what's up
i think it's because are the two's like
the base
of the fraction like how much
in total is there and then the one up
the top is just
like how much of it is there okay all
right all right and i think this is the
same idea crystal is getting at
it was very well said let me see if i
can repeat it and this is an important
idea in fact i want you to write it down
okay when adding fractions
when adding fractions
yep that's why i'm writing it down
okay and adding fractions
we add numerators
only not denominators
okay the question is why why
because it's unfit
the reason is
the one tells us the quantity
how many of these things do i have right
the numerator
tells us quantity
right how many of these things do i have
whereas
the denominator and this is what you
were very very close to saying you had
the right idea the denominator does not
tell us quantity
the denominator tells us
size okay just consider this right
um i have i have quite small feet okay
i've quite small feet
my shoes are size eight okay that's not
very that's not very big for someone my
height anyway
now if i have two size eight shoes right
no one would say oh that's the same as
one size 16
shoe right because that doesn't that
doesn't work you don't add the sizes
of things oh great you add well how many
shoes do you have what quantity
right if i've got two shoes and you've
got two shoes and you've got two shoes
we have six shoes
but their sizes don't add right it's
just six shoes of
all if they were the same size then we
could compare them okay
so parts to underline here right we add
add numerators only that's important
underline that
okay the reason is the numerator tells
us
quantity when you're adding things up
the question is how many do i have
how many it's a quantity question
whereas the denominator tells us
okay how big are all these things you're
adding up right
if the denominator is larger the things
are smaller
right a half that's a pretty big chunk
of the pie
right if we're adding up 100s they'd be
like okay just slice a little bit there
you go
okay if we're adding thousands or
millions they get smaller and smaller
and smaller
okay so therefore let's do some now i
think
on the page you turn to they start off
with ones that already have a common
denominator so there's
one a okay so as we've just seen we add
numerators only not denominators so the
answer would be
4 6. and we should write this first
then we should simplify it that's equal
to two-thirds
please set it out like this don't have
your equal signs running across over
this way it's very hard to read
it's very hard to follow if you've done
that crossfit out or white it out
and um and write it properly okay
now in one question one there's
addition and there's subtraction but
they've all got the common denominator
which makes things nice and easy
okay but let me just move over to here
do we have to simplify
you should simplify yes you should
simplify
let's have a look at question two the
denominators are different
right a half plus a third so
being that the denominators are
different the very first thing you must
do
is get a common denominator and then
they can talk to each other right
so what's the common denominator
six good how many sixths
is a half three three-sixths sixth
is hard to say that's a hard one
how many sixths is a third
two sixths uh plus i'm so confused
okay there you go now i have a common
diet and now i can add the numerators
five over six do i need to simplify no
i'm done okay